weiter geschlossen die korona maßnahmen
sollen wohl nochmal verlängert werden
friseure können aber auf eine frühere
öffnung hoffen
kritik am impfstart
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen in visier des europaparlaments
deutlich unter null die eisige kälte hat
große teile deutschlands fest im griff
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen an
diesem mittwoch an dem wir mit spannung
die beschlüsse der bund länder konferenz
erwarten wie es mit dem shutdown
weitergeht
im sport informiert uns norbert lehmann
ein stück bekannter von mir eigentlich
sollte jetzt schon die pressekonferenz
in berlin begonnen haben aber noch
sitzen sie zusammen die kanzlerin sowie
ministerpräsidenten und präsidentinnen
und versuchen sich auf einen fahrplan
für den ausstieg aus dem shutdown zu
einigen wie geht es den nächsten wochen
weiter bleibt alles zu oder gibt es
ausnahmen
andreas huppert über die streitfragen
corona gipfel im kanzleramt die
einundzwanzigste auflage der bund länder
gespräche und wieder sind die
erwartungen im land groß dass es endlich
klarheit gibt wann wie und unter welchen
voraussetzungen der shutdown aufgehoben
wird
dass wir jetzt runter kommen mit unseren
instanzen zeigt wir sind auf dem
richtigen erfolgreichen weg aber wir
haben auch noch etwas zu tun wir haben
wenn wir im schnitt bei 35 oder 50
incident sind immer noch bundesländer
mit einer hunderter oder 19 inzidenz und
deshalb will allen voran die
bundesregierung den shutdown bis zum 14
märz verlängern die länder schreiben
jedoch in ihr papier den siebten märz
auch bei den friseur betrieben besteht
noch einigungs bedarf öffnen ja ab dem
ersten märz sagt die bundesregierung die
länder wollen den 22 februar
trotzdem atmet die branche auf ja das
ist eine perspektive wo wir lange drauf
gewartet haben auf diesen öffnungszeit
punkt und wir hatten ja gehofft
vielleicht schon etwas früher
aber jetzt sind wir da die sicherheit
haben dann freuen wir uns darauf wir
werden uns vorbereiten eine öffnung
perspektive die sich auch der hotel- und
gaststättenverband gewünscht hätte doch
diese branche muss weiter im lok down
bleiben dem lichte sinken der
infektionszahlen erwarten wir dass es
hier eine konkrete öffnungs perspektive
gibt ohne datum aber eben mit
definitionen der voraussetzungen unter
welchen wir wieder öffnen dürfen
die opposition im bundestag ist von den
bisher bekannten maßnahmen alles andere
als begeistert
es gibt einen weiteren lockdown und
keine perspektive
gerade für schulen gerade für viele
familien und auch für die unternehmen
was wir dringend brauchen ist ein echter
perspektiv plan
es geht nicht mehr dass wir immer ad hoc
entscheidungen einer
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz haben
sondern die perspektiven müssen deutlich
seien die müssen beschlossen werden im
deutschen bundestag noch tagen sie im
kanzleramt feilschen um formulierungen
und termine
noch gibt es keine entscheidung wie
lange deutschland im shutdown bleiben
muss da frage ich gleich mal unseren
beobachter der gespräche in berlin theo
koll woran hakt es warum gibt es noch
kein ergebnis
das kanzleramt ist in seiner
beschlussvorlage und dem vorschlag den
shutter und bis zum 14 märz also um
weitere vier wochen zu verlängern
ziemlich forsch angegangen und hat damit
offensichtlich einige
ministerpräsidenten so verärgert dass es
heute morgen ordentlich gekracht hat so
sehr dass die ministerpräsident erst
einmal in politisch getrennten runden
getagt haben das problem ist im grunde
ja das vertraute dilemma kann man bei
zurückgehenden infektionszahlen dennoch
den shutter und verlängern wegen der
wachsenden sorge vor den mutationen die
linie verläuft er übrigens nicht nur
zwischen bund und ländern sondern auch
zwischen den ländern
heute hat sich das schlicht auch an
daten fest gemacht also shutter und bis
zum siebten oder bis zum 14 märz und ist
haareschneiden wieder möglich ab dem 22
februar oder dem ersten märz ja also
shutdown voraussichtlich bis rein in den
märz aber welche ausnahmen geben für
schulen und friseure
nachdem was zu hören es gibt es so eine
art pandemie doppelbeschluss mindestens
drei wochen verlängerung des shutter und
friseure sollen ab dem ersten märz
wieder öffnen dürfen und die länder
dürfen selbst entscheiden ab wann sie
schulen und kitas wieder aufmachen
wollen also beispielsweise sowie sachsen
das hier schon angekündigt hat ab
kommender woche
das ganze bleibt ein spagat zwischen
unterschiedlichen schäden die die
unterschiedlichen wege anrichten
wirtschaft und bildung sind gravierende
verlierer bei schließungen andererseits
gesundheitliche folgen plus erneute
shutter uns wenn man den mutanten dann
freie bahn verschafft die sich
abzeichnende
doppelbeschluss jetzt wäre der erneute
versuch beiden seiten irgendwie gerecht
zu werden
danke bis hierhin theo wir sprechen uns
natürlich sofort wieder wenn es
definitiven beschlüsse geben sollte was
halten die betroffenen menschen in
deutschland davon vom shutdown der
möglichen verlängerung und den signalen
in richtung öffnung wir haben sie in
magdeburg nach ihren erwartungen gefragt
die kinder müssen zur schule das merkt
man auch dass soziale verhält und wie
sagt wir selber eltern auch man kriegt
zu hause in kohler langsam weil man
wirklich nur am arbeiten ist zuhause
homeschooling und beruf noch unter einen
hut zu kriegen und deswegen ist es schon
mit 15 märz wieder eigentlich einen
schlag naja ins gesicht um eine frau
möchte die haare gefärbt haben zum
beispiel so was also friseure
grundsätzlich sag mal die haben wir alle
ein konzept ausgearbeitet jetzt schon
anfang des jahres und einmal geguckt
inwiefern was muss man machen dass das
alles funktioniert naja die
vorsichtsmaßnahme finde ich schon in
ordnung also es wäre nicht gut wenn
jetzt gelockert wird und das gleich
wieder hoch die die inzidenz also denn
die war ein bisschen vorsichtiger sein
natürlich gehen wird und dass es hat man
eben schon sie haben es eben schon
gehört wenn die schulen wieder öffnen
das kann wohl jedes bundesland für sich
entscheiden aber familienministerin
giffey mahnt hier dürfen wir keinen tag
verlieren
es steht ja auch zu viel auf dem spiel
für schüler und schülerinnen besonders
für die die sozial benachteiligt sind
die keinen computer haben und vielleicht
auch noch sprachprobleme ein beispiel
von verena geld für übungen für die
schule teilen sich massa und riad ein
handy auf dem kleinen bildschirm mathe
machen
oft muss auch ihr vater unterstützen
nicht ganz einfach
ich wollte einen kunden macht der
computer aber ist bei den sei jetzt
finanziell nicht drin wie so vieles
nicht die syrische familie lebt von
hartz iv
zu fünft wohnen sie auf 70 quadratmetern
dazu noch die sprachbarriere
eltern und kinder sind mit der situation
überfordert
das ist fehlt der klasse ist ganz
kompliziert für mich das eigentlich mein
sohn braucht ein beständiger dann kann
ihr onkel sich kümmern mit dieser
sprache
laut einer aktuellen studie zeigt ein
jahr nach beginn der pandemie fast jedes
dritte kind in deutschland psychische
auffälligkeiten
besonders belastet durch die kontakt
beschränkungen sind kinder aus sozial
schwachen familien niedergeschlagenheit
und kopf und bauchschmerzen stiegen um
jeweils ca 10 prozentpunkte und haben
sich im vergleich zu der zeit vor der
pandemie damit fast verdoppelt kinder
aus familien mit wenig einkommen während
massa bekommen unterstützung im
kinderhaus mal statt
bei vielen von ihnen ist die schule die
einzige struktur die gegeben ist und
auch die fällt gerade weg fatal für
diese kinder sagt der leiter der
einrichtung es gibt kein klares konzept
wie diese katastrophe oder diese sehr
schwierige situation für viele viele
schüler in irgendeiner art und weise zu
lösen ist friert und massa bedeuten die
nachmittage im kinderhaus ein bisschen
halt in einer schwierigen zeit
und so sehen die zahlen derzeit aus der
sieben tage incidents wert liegt laut
robert koch institut bundesweit bei 68
binnen 24 stunden haben die
gesundheitsämter 8000 72 neuinfektionen
übermittelt dabei sind auch nach
meldungen vom vortag
im vergleich zum vergangenen mittwoch
bedeutet das ein minus von rund 1.600
813 menschen sind in verbindung mit
kuwait 19 gestorben
auf dauer sänken werden die zahlen wohl
nur wenn mehr geimpft wird aber da hat
ja bekanntermaßen weil die eu kommission
zu spät und zu wenig impfstoff für ihre
27 länder bestellt habe
diese kritik musste sich
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen zuletzt immer lauter anhören
heute vom eu parlament wo sie zwar
fehler einräumte aber die europäische
strategie auch verteidigte an der klinik
es war eine einladung ins
europaparlament die eu
kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
nicht ablehnen konnte zu viel kritik hat
sich angestaut am impfstart in europa
das eingeständnis man habe fehler
gemacht kommt dann kein zufall auf
deutsch
wir waren spät dran bei der zulassung
wir waren zu optimistisch bei der
massenproduktion und vielleicht waren
wir uns auch zu sicher dass das
bestellte tatsächlich pünktlich
geliefert wird eine prise selbstkritik
zugleich verteidigt von der leyen aber
den gemeinsamen europäischen impfstoff
einkauf die mehrheit der abgeordneten
sie das ähnlich beklagt aber fehlende
transparenz in den verhandlungen
grüne und linke halten die geschwärzten
verträge mit impfstoffherstellern in die
kamera noch immer sei unklar welches
land wann wie viele dosen geliefert
bekomme von der leyens auftritt komme zu
spät
meine frau präsidentin was wir bis jetzt
gesehen haben ist ein mangel an
kommunikation ausweichen vor
parlamentarischer kontrolle weigerung
journalistenfragen zu beantworten in
einer krise ist dass das rezept
kritisierte die linksfraktion fordert
einen parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschuss von ganz rechts
kommt der appell zum rücktritt stehen
sie zu ihrer verantwortung tun wie
europa und sich selbst einen gefallen
treten sie endlich zurück es ist
überfällig
von der leyen will der krise mit dem
blick nach vorn und einer arbeitsgruppe
begegnen die die impfstoffproduktion
weiter ankurbeln soll
ein rücktritt von der leyens kommt für
die mehrheit der abgeordneten nicht in
frage mehr selbstkritik und konkrete
antworten hätten sich schon viele im
parlament gewünscht von der leyen aber
duckt sich weg und überlässt die
antworten am ende der debatte ihrer
gesundheitskommissarin sich dem insekten
sterben entgegenzustellen das hatte sich
die große koalition schon vor fast
eineinhalb jahren auf die fahnen
geschrieben
heute nun einigte sie sich nach langem
ringen auf das wie zum einen sollen
lebensräume für insekten besser
geschützt zum anderen der einsatz von
pflanzenschutzmitteln eingeschränkt
werden
viele bauern sehen dadurch ihre existenz
bedroht und habe
deshalb auch heute wieder demonstriert
oliver deuker berichtet jakob von
richthofen betreibt ackerbau vor den
toren hannovers getreide mais hafer
zuckerrübe 300 hektar das insektenschutz
gesetz sieht er kritisch
also ich würde schon sagen dass die
landwirtschaft einen einfluss auf den
artenrückgang hat wie hoch der ist da
gibt es eben verschiedene untersuchungen
und studien dazu
und das ist eben auch unsere ganz große
kritik dass wir sagen wir müssen
dringend nach den ursachen forschen
ergebnisoffen bringt ja nichts irgendwie
in aktionismus zu verfallen irgendwas zu
machen was aber nachher im ergebnis da
nichts bringt mit dem gesetz sollen
biotope wie streuobstwiesen oder
artenreiches grünland als lebensraum für
insekten stärker geschützt werden der
einsatz von pflanzenschutzmitteln soll
gesenkt werden der unkrautvernichter
glyphosat ist ab 2024 ganz verboten
ich weiß aber auch dass die debatte
zwischen umwelt und landwirtschaft
interessen nicht immer einfach mal in
der letzten zeit aber es ist möglich
beide seiten zusammen zu führen ohne
artenvielfalt gibt es keine
landwirtschaft und uni landwirtschaft
keine abhilfe
heute morgen trecker demo in berlin mal
wieder insektenschutz ja aber nicht mit
dem rasenmäher die landwirte fürchten um
ihre existenz
dieses aktionsprogramm insektenschutz
ist eigentlich ein export programm für
die deutsche industrie und zur
zerstörung unser land unserer heimischen
landwirtschaft die unsere bevölkerung
mit hochwertigen lebensmittel versorgt
und das ist ein unding und ist auch
ökologisch weltweit gesehen ökologische
katastrophe das insektenschutz gesetz
keine entscheidung für die grüne wiese
sondern vom grünen tisch bemängeln
landwirte die sich mehr beteiligung
daran gewünscht hätten
um die angeschlagenen beziehungen
zwischen deutschland und russland ging
es heute im bundestag und damit auch um
die umstrittene gaspipeline nord stream
2 die forderung der opposition das
projekt nach der verurteilung von alexei
navalny zu stoppen
aussenminister maß hielt dagegen diese
sanktion träfe die falschen indirekt
etwa deutsche unternehmen außerdem würde
eine wirtschaftliche isolierung
russlands nur russland nur weiter in die
arme chinas treiben ein staatliches
informationsangebot zu gesundheitsfragen
bär kann dagegen
das haben dass google das portal des
gesundheitsministeriums aber bevorzugt
das gehe nicht entschied dass münchen
münchner landgericht in einer
einstweiligen verfügung
und darum geht es wer informationen zu
bestimmten krankheiten googelt fand
bisher an prominenter stelle eine
infobox die vom ministerium verantwortet
wird erst danach dann informationen
kommerzieller anbieter ein unternehmen
hatte geklagt wegen verzerrung des
wettbewerbs
wer in polen heute einen der privaten
sender einschaltet sieht meist das einen
schwarzen bildschirm der text dazu hier
sollte ihr lieblingsprogramm sein
mit der aktion protestieren rund 50
unabhängige sender und zeitungen gegen
eine geplante steuer auf werbeeinnahmen
sie werfen der nationalkonservativen
regierung vor sie wolle so die
medienunternehmen schwächen und die
pressefreiheit einschränken
die stärksten schneefälle sind vorbei
die regie am himmel übernimmt nun auf
die sonne nachts verwandelt sich
deutschland aber in eine riesige
tiefkühltruhe letzte nacht sank das
thermometer vor allem vom münsterland
bis nach sachsen richtig in den keller
der tiefpunkt mühlhausen in thüringen
mit minus 26,7 grad über das große
frieren berichtet thomas garcia
kalt kälter karlsfeld in sachsen ist
besonders im erzgebirge eiszeit die
fenster blind vor frost das leben wie
eingefroren
auch auf autobahnen stillstand im schnee
bevor sich die lage tags entspannt staus
viele lkw bleiben unterwegs trotz
fahrverbots denn den brummi abstellen
ist oft unmöglich wie hier zwischen
halle und magdeburg so ab 16 uhr ist
sind die rastplätze alle voll
die folge pause machen geht nur auf der
autobahn bab a 14 in sachsen-anhalt
schlafen
auf dem standstreifen wasserstraßen
ebenfalls nicht nur der eisbrecher kommt
noch durch bei osnabrück gesperrt der
mittellandkanal der längste künstliche
wasserweg deutschlands noch mal ins
erzgebirge da zeigt sich auch fallendes
wasser kann erstarren den temperaturen
so sehr stürzen und unsere norbert und
zum auftakt der biathlon wm im
slowenischen pokljuka
und den hatte sich die deutsche
mixed-staffel ganz anders vorgestellt
bittere enttäuschung statt eingeplante
medaille am ende nur platz sieben für
denise herrmann franziska preuß am käfer
und einen ganz schwachen ihre gläser für
die deutschen ist ein gebrauchter tag
und besonders schlecht läuft für den
staat läufer erik lesser vier nachlader
in der loipe zu langsam die enttäuschung
riesig weil der komplette leistung
beider unterirdisch und da kann ich fast
dankbar sein dass am ende platz sieben
rausgesprungen ist denn nach den männern
lesser und käufer bot denise herrmann
als dritte noch einmal auf riskiert
alles drei fehler stehend aber zuviel
norwegen als titelverteidiger mit
schlussläuferin reiseland zu wm-gold
dahinter österreich vor schweden die
sportliche überraschung auf platz zwei
die österreicher unbeeindruckt von
positiven corona test ihres deutschen
trainers ricco groß er der einzige dm
fall der zeit und während andere feiern
ist der deutsche wm auftakt sportlich
verpasst mit einer minute rückstand
reicht heute nur für platz sieben
alexander zverev hat als einziger
deutscher tennisspieler die dritte runde
bei den australian open in melbourne
erreicht
der hamburger gewann gegen den
us-amerikaner maxime kresse souverän in
drei sätzen
nein dieses bild hier täuscht denn
himmelschreiend schwach war die leistung
des 23 jährigen gegen den gleichaltrigen
franco amerikaner max im crazy zu keiner
zeit der fast zwei meter große aufschlag
riese dessen konsequente serve and
volley spiel
viele spektakuläre ballwechsel
ermöglichte hatte aber letztlich keine
chance
gegen das variantenreiche repertoire der
deutsche nummer eins in zwei stunden und
drei glatten sätzen besiegt alexander
zverev den us amerikaner max in crazy
und kann sich nun auf sein
drittrundenmatch gegen den bisher stark
aufspielenden franzosen adrian mannarino
vorbereiten und gegen den hat es wäre
schon fünfmal gespielt und fünfmal
gewonnen weil danken und ob sie gewonnen
haben das verraten ihnen jetzt die
zahlen vom mittwoch lotto sie lauten 5
19 21 27 32 46 und die superzahl 6
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
beim winterwetter mischt jetzt immer
häufiger die sonne mit ob es deshalb
aber auch milder wird das verrät uns
gleich katja honnefer so viel von uns
für den moment gleich geht es hier
weiter mit einem zdf spezial zu den
beratungen in berlin
und auf jeden fall überträgt zdf heute
live die gesamte pressekonferenz in
unserer app und auf den social media
plattformen
danke für ihr interesse und noch einen
interessanten abend bis morgen 19 uhr
tschüss